у нас снаряди на снаряди установки
дуже багато менше він розірвався
мінометних мін
прапорщик по вологу бурчав про зону ато
вилита 2014
його взвод пробувати розминання об'єкті
цивільної інфраструктури знайдеш і
снаряди у маші 500 українські сапери
чи знаєш у слов'ян складається вам у
жителі пустимо і підходів і розповів і
гостю дурі
артилерійський снаряд каміном від нами на
чистому гарна ти за два уроки конфлікту
на донбасі саперами інфраструктурою у
чистого вигляду ви бухун забезпечених
предметів моя ж 280 гектарів землі
вся кава прогавила і сліди вище чину мр
мовою обидва набряк на смугу приватних засобів
захисту частка у всі проблеми ви вирішили
представлені до сівон і передав
15 брана бажаєте ешелоні до початку війни
до початку ризикових дій тут всі служби
розминання україни знаєш каджол і майже
75000 ви бух вона безтурботних прилаштував фіч
різних за 1 of відбувався в рази вас у
рази образі розум з українською та службам
і створі азарів єдиним про іменних куль
протеуса перил видно з каменю до даєте
роботи через два диверсантів та
терористів нехай цнс знайшли на залізаті
проводиться лише до Дженні
команда приготувати у вогонь
павла вилиці вина ж знаєш кодовий
близько чотирьох із половиною тисяч
боєприпасів сапери закриваються місцевих
жителів буквальному значенню слова нехай і
треба б ти собі нові корпуси вбиває
сексу б вояка лікувати я хочу людина атр
та майями новий духову травму
будуть поні vaccine кінсі смак люди на
можеш так ти кров'ю
шкіра нарик провини як мінімум 5 уроки
врубить розминання у тіні і павла можна
його і дав
за закласти видно явності ресурсів
оджіно вигляд сьогодні сапери регулярно
знаходять
про донбас снаряда годинник в іншу
світлову провину